all right let's get into audience
questions for the week the first one
very very ripe for people to be very
angry with me the question is hey David
why are you ignoring Tulsi Gabbard all
the time which is just so funny because
I I talk about Tulsi Gabbard as much as
I talk about any of the other
one-percenters except I'd say Andrew
yang because Andrew yang has been on our
show three times Tulsi zhh welcome any
time and I'd be glad to interview her on
the program i talked about marianne
williamson a little bit after the second
debate because I thought she actually
did notably well in that debate but
still big picture especially after
finding out that she was offering New
Age woo stuff to her campaign list which
is crazy I mean she's just another one
of these one-percenters that's going
nowhere the problem I don't think is
that I am talking about Tulsi Gabbard
not enough she's basically getting the
same attention for me as the other zero
to one percenters who are not going to
last much longer the problem is that
there is a cult of personality around
Tulsi that makes people see that when i
don't talk about amy klobuchar or i
don't talk about kirsten gillibrand it
doesn't warrant emails to me or
complaints or any kind of investigation
into what my biases are but not talking
about Tulsi there definitely is
something going on there this is again
what I was talking about a couple weeks
ago when I said I sort of self-censor on
some issues because there's no upside
and in this case it's not even that it's
there's no specific focus or lack of
focus on Tulsi on this program there are
lots of people in my audience who see
everything through Tulsi colored glasses
I guess I would say where when I do talk
about Tulsi Gabbard if it's anything
short of completely glowing and
everything is just so amazing that Tulsi
does I'm some kind of you know anti
Tulsi chill or Democratic this or that
who even knows what the argument is if I
don't talk about Tulsi the absence of
discussions of Tulsi are what is the
problem even though I'm also barely
talking about any of the other
candidates that are polling zero to one
or zero to one and a half
so this is an example of what I was
talking about no matter what I do if I
talk about her in anything but the most
glowing terms if I don't talk about her
no matter what I'm clearly doing
something wrong let me say it in
completely clear terms I have no
particular favor or disfavor for Tulsi
Gabbard compared to John Delaney or
Hickenlooper or Marianne Williamson or
whoever I mean okay I find the New Age
guru stuff weird with Marianne
Williamson I see Tulsi Gabbard as a
candidate who like all of the candidates
I can find things I agree with her on
there are things I disagree on but I
basically pay attention to her in
proportion to what I believe is the
appropriate amount of attention that
should be paid and given that she is
polling zero to one and a half percent
given that she has not done particularly
well in the debates given that she's not
come up with any particularly
interesting policy for example the way
that I think Andrew yang has that's all
it is I'm just talking about her in
proportion to how important I think she
is in this race you can disagree with me
about that you can tell me David no
here's why toll C really is the person
that even though she's polling zero to
one like all these other people you
should be talking about way more then we
can have a conversation but just saying
David the fact that you are quote
ignoring Tulsi Gabbard is the problem
this is laughable this is the exact cult
of personality stuff that I've been
talking about when I talk about all of
these issues that if you don't say the
right thing there is a sliver of the
left that will absolutely go crazy and
attack you